is in Isaiah 66 22 and 23 it says we
will come before God to worship on
Sabbath and on the new moon but in
Revelation 21 23 there will not be any
new moon in the new Earth could you help
us understand this difficult passage
well you almost got it right
there'll be no moon in heaven
but we're not going to stay up there
blessed are the meek for they shall
inherit what
Heaven's going to come back down to
earth God's going to bring us down here
and his original plan will be resumed
God made the moon before there was any
such thing as Sin in the earth and so
the moon will be there the one that God
makes and we will see it and it will
control the months and we'll have
special services on the new moon next
please Pastor what about Saul and The
Witch of Endor
yeah we talked about death the other
night and witches and all of that and
somebody has jumped to that section in
the Bible where a king had so rebelled
against God that God wouldn't talk to
him
and so he goes to a witch to try to find
out what God intended now if God
wouldn't talk to him why would anyone
think a witch could do it
on behalf of God
so what Saul's sorry went over to Endor
and met with a witch against the known
will of God
and he asked that witch to bring
up Samuel
now the witch brought up something
first of all first of all use your mind
this thing is coming from the wrong
direction
if Samuel was in heaven and some believe
he should have come down this thing came
up
but that's not the end of the story
before you get yourself confused read
the end of the story the Bible says over
in in first Chronicles it gives us the
end of the story in chapter 10 and I'm
going to read verse 13. and I want you
to listen this is First Chronicles 10
and verse 13 and I have it these pages
are sticking and I've got it now so Saul
died he did what
for his transgression
which he committed against the Lord even
against the word of the Lord which he
kept not and also for asking counsel of
one that had a familiar Spirit to
inquire of it Saul was punished with
death
for going to a witch next please
you know Pastor it's nice to see young
people here isn't it absolutely and they
are asking you some hard questions
here's a child that wants to know when
we get to heaven will we have wings
well
the Bible tells us we're going to mount
up on wings as Eagles
that's Isaiah 40 and verse 31.
now you take that the way you want to
the Bible says we will Mount up with
wings as evils
in any case we won't need forged and
Volkswagens
and Cadillacs and lexuses to Get Around
Heaven
we will Mount up on wings of eagles
the Bible says that very clearly those
that wait on the Lord shall renew their
strength and mount up with wings of
eagles Isaiah 40 and verse 31 next
please you know that was a powerful
sermon here's one that says okay pastor
what did I see because I know I saw
something
what did I see on Wednesday night we
talked about ghosts and Spokes and hats
and poltergeists and whatever else said
no one has and called what did I see
well first of all let's conclude that
the word of God is true would you say
Amen if you believe that and we read to
you from the Bible where the Bible says
the dead no not anything the Bible says
they shall rise no more till the heavens
pass away and the Bible says they shall
return no more to their house the Bible
says neither have they any more anything
forever to do with anything that's done
under the sun now if we conclude that
the Bible is true what you claim you saw
was not a dead relative would you say
Amen to that well what was it I think
that's a fair question Revelation 12 and
verse 9 there the Bible says in the
Great Dragon was cast out that old
serpent called the devil and Satan which
deceiveth he does what
which deceiveth the whole world he was
cast out into the Earth and his angels
were cast out with him would you say
Amen now we're starting since it's
spiritism and you see spirits these are
spirits they're evil spirits that's what
you see Revelation 16 and verse 14 for
they are spirits of devils spirits of
what working miracles Revelation 16 and
verse 14. now let's read a very striking
text found in the book of second
Corinthians it should be chapter 11 and
let's see if it is in verse 14. I
believe that's where it is and no Marvel
for Satan himself is transformed into an
angel of Light therefore it is no great
thing if his ministers also be
transformed as Ministers of
righteousness the devil can transform
himself
oh but you say wait a minute my
grandmother told me things that only a
grandmother could know because she was
there well the devil was there too
he knows all about you
you've been after you all of your life
he knows your habits your weaknesses he
suits Temptations Just to you and so he
transforms himself and appears in the
darkness he never appears in the light
he appears in a dark room of corridor as
your grandmother why does he do this
because he wants to displace Faith he's
using the first lie he ever told in the
Garden of Eden he said they shall not
surely die and he wants you to think
dead folks are dead
he wants to displace Faith he doesn't
want you to believe God and you keep
following that stuff and he will lead
you astray most people who get involved
in it end up in pitiful condition the
wife of our President Abraham Lincoln
wanted so badly to communicate with her
husband she got involved with this and
ended up virtually insane next please
Dr Brooks should we call our preachers
father
now you are beginning to ask some very
important questions
I will read an answer because if you ask
you must have the truth
Matthew chapter 23 and verse 9 the Bible
says and call no man
your father upon the Earth for one is
your father which is in heaven they are
some attributes there are some
characteristics they are some
prerogatives that belong only to God
Matthew 23 9 says don't call any man on
Earth your father next please
Dr Brooks I've always wondered whether
the portraits and pictures and actors
portraying Jesus are accurate according
to his physical appearance is the is
there passage in the Bible that will
clarify this for me I don't believe
there is a passage that will clarify
that idea we have what we call
representations of the Lord and they
have been repeated over so many
centuries that when you see a picture
that's supposed to represent the Lord
you automatically say that's Jesus
but the Bible doesn't give us that kind
of detailed description
the Bible says in Isaiah 53 by the way
Isaiah was called The Gospel prophet and
he said many things about Jesus and he
said when he would come there would be
no Beauty in him that he should be
desired now I have no doubt that Christ
was a fine specimen of a man
but he was not one of these
Ultra handsome Heartbreakers that
sometimes people fall for because of
looks
the beauty in him was his character
that always would shine through his
countenance in his voice in his smile
and in the moral Restraint of his eyes
but not a handsome fella to create the
kind of saccharine sentimentalism that
we find a great deal in religion today
in Luke Chapter 2 the Bible simply tells
us that the child grew and whacked
strong that you will find in verse 40
and if you read verse 52 said he
increased in stature and in wisdom
ladies and gentlemen Jesus grew up in
the Middle East he did a lot of walking
now I've got my own idea of what he
looked like
I believe that Jesus was strong athletic
because he walked everywhere
he took long strides he was not gay
he was Sunday
I doubt that he had blue eyes but it
doesn't matter
he was a Jew
and had those characteristics of of Jews
ladies and gentlemen it is not necessary
that Jesus belonged to any particular
group
he is called the desire of all Nations
I've been in South America where he's
painted with a distinctly Spanish look
I've been in the East where he's painted
with almond eyes that's all right
let people appreciate him because he
belongs to everybody what'd you say Amen
next
he is a child again that wants to know
if Satan shaped like a beast or a man
well I'll tell you what Satan is a Great
Deceiver and he'd like you to think that
he's shaped like a beast you see he
doesn't want you to know him when he
shows up
he wants you to think he's red
with horns and Hooves like a goat and a
tail
why that's a caricature that he invented
and it is far from the truth the Bible
tells us something about him first of
all he was created he was an angel his
name was lucify
a compound word which means light from
looks light bearer light bearer that's
what he was and he was in attendant at
the Throne of God known as a covering
cherub and the Bible says that he was
perfect
Ezekiel 18 and verse 14. he was perfect
he had someone said Perfect Pitch he was
the quiet leader could sing four-point
harmony at the same time the Bible says
that his heart was lifted up because of
his duty and in that same chapter the
Bible says God will bring him to ashes
he's going to burn in hell but he was
not a beast he did not have hoofs he was
a handsome creature perfect from the
hand of God sin has defiled him and
degraded him and uglified him and
eventually will destroy him our friends
out here are learning so many marvelous
things where did God come from was he
here at the beginning of time
first of all the Bible says can any man
by searching find out God
transcends us so much and with our
finiteness we cannot understand all
about it now there's a lot of body we
can't understand remember our subject on
what is God like
The Ten Commandments our transcript of
his character we can know what he's like
he is merciful he's kind he is good he's
long-suffering he loves unspeakably all
of these things we may know
but to know where he came from is asking
more than can be answered God is eternal
he has
immortality that never was a time when
he wasn't there never will be a time
when he isn't would you say Amen
oh you're sleeping I can't understand it
of course you can't when we all get to
heaven we'll understand it better by and
by
now just a minute Dr Brooks didn't Jesus
tell the thief on the cross he would go
that day into Paradise
oh well now we've had we've had people
say that
we told you the other night we read to
you that David was not in heaven Acts 2
29-34 you remember that if you do say
Amen you can talk to him and and we
indicated that the Saints sleep in their
graves and wait on the coming of Our
Lord the Bible says they'll rise first
then the rest of us who might live until
that time will be caught up together
with them in the clouds to meet the Lord
in the air and so someone says didn't
Jesus tell the thief on the cross he
would be with him that day in paradise
the answer to your question is a
resounding no
he did not tell him that
now I'm sure some say but wait a minute
I read it well let me put it this way I
have an illustration I'd like to use a
man who owned a large company sent one
of his representatives to Europe to buy
material
when the man got over there the things
cost a lot more than they expected
so he sent his boss a telegram and said
these are the prices should I buy
the boss wired him back and he bought a
lot of things brought him back to
America and was called in on the carpet
the boss said why in the world did you
waste our money like that he said well I
sent you a wire and asked you if I
should buy I got the wire right here it
said no price too high
his boss said let me see that that's not
what I said I said no price too high
so the problem was one of
punctuation
I'm going to read it twice and I want
you to listen
Jesus said verily I say unto thee today
shalt thou be with me in Paradise that's
the way it's read
the way it should read in the Greek is
I'm telling you today
Karma
Thou shalt be with me in parent all but
you say it's easy if you say that how
can you prove it I'll prove it with a
familiar Easter story
Jesus went into the tomb and stayed
until Sunday morning
and a lady by the name of Mary was there
near the tomb weeping but she heard
someone call a name
and when she answered she thought he was
the god
but when he spoke to her again she knew
him
and she reached for him wouldn't you
now how many remember this Jesus said
touch me not for I have not yet ascended
to my father have you heard that if you
have Say Amen
you'll find it you'll find it in John 20
and 17 and you'll find the other in Luke
23 43. Jesus wasn't even in heaven
Friday
so how could the thief be with him in
Paradise when he didn't go till Sunday
thank you very much
okay our seniors Pastor I'd like to know
if I'm unable to get down on my knees to
pray will my prayers be less effective
oh my dear
yes your prayers are heard prayer is not
posture
posture has to do with respect and
rivers but prayer is not posture
Jesus told the story of a man who went
to the temple to pray and when he got
there there was a Pharisee there and the
Pharisee said Lord I'm glad I'm not like
other men even this public can stand
ahead I go to church I pay tithe I do
this I do that and then Jesus said that
man stood he did what
smote on his breast and said Lord have
mercy on me a sinner and Jesus said that
man went down Justified prayer is not
posture one day I was driving a car and
Ice had covered the road and when I
topped the hill another car was across
the road and I couldn't stop
one of the greatest prayers I ever
prayed I'm sitting behind the wheel
working with it eyes wide open and
crying unto the Lord and when I got to
that car mine went right around it
prayer is not posture prayer has to do
with your mind and your attitude in your
heart
you can pray lying in your bed thank you
master last week on 60 Minutes the
doctor put a lady to death and operated
on her brain for hours after they
resuscitated her she didn't remember any
near-death experiences she didn't
remember anything why do some people
claim to have near-death experiences and
claim to go to heaven and return back to
the land of the living thank you Pastor
and this is the last one beloved I don't
have any intention of offending anyone
but if you ask me I have to tell you
when this lady went to the hospital they
didn't put her to death
you know what death means
death means you're not alive
death is the cessation of life she was
not dead
she was in a controlled condition
her heart was kept beating even if by a
machine
the blood was still coursing through her
veins and then when they revived her she
was better
now having said that
all of these things that are called near
death if you just listen to the language
it defines itself they are not death
experiences they are near their
experience if you die
that's it
amen
and the mind is a marvelous thing
just stop and think of the dreams you
dream you ever dream of anything
fantastic I have
I've dreamed I was flying
I've dreamed all kinds of things I
remember dreaming once the Lord had come
and I'm watching church members who
couldn't rise up the meeting
and I've never forgotten that dream but
it wasn't real
the mind is a marvelous instrument and
when you are in that distressed
condition
then the mind will show you things upon
which you have been concentrating
and many of them are aberrant but you're
not dead
you're not dead you are near death if
you die
thank you thank you very much
can a person that accepts the SDA
doctrines pays tithes attend services on
Saturday it has difficult with a
cigarette habit be baptized all beloved
Jesus gives complete Victory would you
say Amen
and if we know that you have not given
up such a habit we would not baptize you
but don't despair there are people
sitting here right now who have given up
greater habits than tobacco by the power
of Jesus Christ learn to trust him and
keep on coming we're going to talk about
this on a night real soon and when we do
and you understand what Jesus wants and
why Always for our good always for our
good
I know I don't have any doubt I know he
is able to give you the victory if you
want it next please Pastor is anybody in
heaven now yes there are people up there
Moses is there and not only that but uh
Enoch is there and Elijah is there and
then there's reference the Four and
Twenty Elders redeemed from the earth
they are there now by the way uh we
don't have any guarantee of others there
might be we just don't know
but we do know that Moses was there and
Elijah because they came down to meet
the Lord on the Mount of transfiguration
what we want to do is get up there and
meet everybody
it says in the Bible Pastor that we are
goats and lambs and God is our maker
when God comes again will we turn into
goats
it's a sheep and goats sheep and goat
and God uses these sort of analogous to
two kinds of people you've got the Sheep
who is submissive always the Sheep is
submissive but the goat always has to
butt
I would obey the Lord but
I know it's the truth but
you better get changed from a goat to a
sheep down here before Jesus comes next
please Reverend Brooks I'm a new
attendee I know that people clap for the
singers should I clap for the sermon
should I clap for prayer should I clap
if the sermon isn't too good should I
clap if the prayer isn't too good or the
music isn't too good I think the music
was great and I think the sermon was
great please clarify I'm going to give
you a secret I'm not too accustomed to
clapping in church myself
but we're dealing with a cultural issue
and not a spiritual one necessarily
if you go to Russia as some of us have
done and you are introduced everybody
stands up an applauds it's a cultural
thing
it's not a man of right and wrong but
what's best and it is becoming
increasingly more common in this country
to applaud I hope you are applauding the
good news and not the person and when I
preached please though next Please Mr
question man what do the trees that are
mentioned in Revelation 7th chapter mean
they mean trees in Revelation chapter 7
the angels are holding the Four Winds
and the winds are not to hurt the Earth
nor the trees tell God's servants are
sealed in their foreheads right now
we've got a lot of stock in peace
efforts and the U.N and that sort of
thing and I'm sure they can be used to
help save human life but when the Four
Winds are released in the time of
trouble that is predicted in Prophecy
comes and the Great Tribulation there
isn't the man alive that can forbear
and until then
it is the patience of God that holds
back destruction that meetings like this
all over the world can be completed and
men and women who ever intend to do
right can have an opportunity next
please from a young person Pastor on
Halloween can we go if something holy or
will we still be disobeying God
oh I don't quite understand do you mean
go out as a ghoul or a ghost or
something on Halloween
back East
when my kids went to private school they
went out at Halloween time and collected
food for the poor you can make something
good out of it Halloween is a holiday
that comes from All Hallows Eve which
comes from paganism it was believed that
on this particular date the spirits of
the Dead came now we've already cleared
that up haven't we and that they
tormented people and harassed folk who
were not kind to them and so the church
kind of went along with this it was on
all hella's Eve that Martin Luther
nailed his thesis to the church to Ed
Wittenberg but we don't believe much in
Halloween because we don't believe that
spirits of dead people do anything
amen the Bible says so now if that night
is interesting to young people and you
want to go collect food for the poor or
something good I don't see anything
wrong with it next Please Mr evangelist
why is the Bible called the word of God
when men wrote it
oh in second Timothy 3 16 the Bible says
all scripture is given by inspiration of
God even though being rooted it is not
thought inspired maybe a word inspired
but not thought inspired forgive me
forgive me I don't mean that what I mean
is men did not come up with the thoughts
the Holy Spirit inspired them and
inspired their thoughts so that they
could write what is known as the word of
God Peter said holy men spake as they
were moved by the Holy Ghost therefore
it is rightfully called the word of God
and God calls it there if any man hear
my word is his counsel obey Pastor
Brooks do you think that a woman who
keeps with the Fashions of today should
be called a Christian meaning those who
wear short dresses and uh-huh a few
other things here if you had a church
could this person hold an office in your
church I hope somebody's not getting it
somebody I I don't know what this is all
about but I will have a message to you
from the word of God on modesty amen
and I invite you to wait for it it'll be
very interesting God isn't making
everything wrong but some things are and
modesty is a principle
length is not modesty is
what is short on our child uh
might be appropriate but on an adult it
might not be
modesty is the rule and we will talk
about it from the word of God elong
Mr evangelist some people call pastors
Reverend is this a title that we should
call any man
I don't think so and we are not called
that we call our men pastoral Elder
frankly I prefer to be called Pastor now
the Bible says in Psalm 111 and verse 9
holy and Reverend is his name and it's
not used as a noun there but as an
adjective holy and Reverend is God's
name and incidentally before we finish
out here maybe we'll tell you how all of
this got into the church next please
Pastor Brooks I wish you would explain
Isaiah 42 21 doesn't this mean that
Jesus would change the law I know the
text it says he will magnify it and make
it honorable
now beloved how on Earth can we construe
that to mean he's going to change it he
will magnify it magnify it you know the
doctor told me one day Brooks you need
glasses for here and there
I said do you mean bifocals he said yes
the time has come
and these bifocals magnify now I'm going
to magnify this piece of paper and let's
see if it disappears or changes
no not really
God said I will magnify the law and make
it honorable and when you magnify a
thing you make it clearer when somebody
say Amen
more easily seen
and the Lord came and fulfilled the law
lived it himself and then gave
additional information so that we don't
get trapped by the letter of the law but
rather follow the spirit of the law in
doing that
he said if you hate your brother You're
a murderer
he said if you look at a woman and lust
after her you're an adulterer
in saying those things he made it
clearer magnifying does not mean change
or annihilate next please
our final question for tonight Mr
evangelist I think I've got you how can
the Bible be kept on a round world when
it's Sabbath here it's Sunday someplace
else can the Bible
when it's Sabbath here it's suddenly
somewhere else and that's true I made a
trip to around the world I didn't go
directly to Japan I came around to Japan
and I went to church on Sabbath in Tokyo
I got on a plane Saturday night flew to
Honolulu and was Sabbath again
and uh what did I do I enjoyed both of
them in fact I believe I owed the Lord
one because one day I was flying to New
Zealand and we left on Friday and in the
middle of the ocean something happened
you all who've done that you know what
I'm talking about and when the sun came
up it was Sunday and there was no
Sabbath at all and it was a strange
feeling for me I opened my Bible and we
do that every day and we worshiped and
prayed on the plane and I'm sitting up
there at 40 000 feet and I said wow this
seemed like it ought to be Sabbath but
it didn't descend it and I'm not going
to keep Sunday so I got me a newspaper
and read it
how can you keep Sabbath on a round
world I have an illustration that will
answer this
let's say a plane left Dallas Texas
bound for Seattle Washington are you
with me
and you want to go to Seattle
the plane leaves Dallas
at 12 noon
arrives in New Mexico
at 1 pm
gets to Phoenix at 2 p.m
gets to Los Angeles at 3 P.M
gets to Seattle at 5 pm
it's the same place
now you don't have to worry about that
plane at 12. that's when the folk from
Dallas get on
you don't have to worry about getting on
it one that's when the folk from New
Mexico get on what you'd better do if
you plan to catch that plane is be ready
when it gets to Phoenix then you get on
board and stop worrying about the folk
in Los Angeles would you say Amen out
there
the Earth is round and it turns from
west to east at 1038 miles an hour and
it does give us this variance that you
mentioned you keep the Sabbath when it
gets to you
that's all the Lord asks thank you for
your questions